Xin chào, we will in Ganga học sinh
Thật mệt, trong mình nè qua
Gó rất nhiều, we will in Ganga học sinh
Nen dình, người dạ, hoải thầy
Thầy ơi, khi nào thầy giang
Le phật liên mật
Thầy ơi, em bị bất tốt
1 tuần gái, 1 khoảng dù dễ
Ờ, thầy, tiêm của học, 1 phật liên mật hấp
Thầy ơi, em muốn tham ra
Vào đôi để không xích dọi bất liên mật
Thầy có phụ trận em được không?
Hãy chả nơi cho
Các có hoa chết
Dí hụi ngay thầy điều thương hả hó đi quyến uống
Và kè không xin
Thầy xe
Hãy giang
Lớm, vật liên mật
Giang rất kè không xin 2 cao người ngọt
Để vớm học bất li của thầy giường
Các em xe
Tự thầy
Thậm chắc ngốc, mù vật li
Lớm bật
Đông thầy thầy sẽ
Truyv cả hướt
Để cho các em
Yếu thích
Náp mây đồ với một học bật li
Thầy bị cho thầy giang xe
Em ngã
Thầy, thầy bây giờ, thầy bụi đồ ai
Thầy giang thích thú và em
Náp mây với một học
Nếu em ra hó
Mã mong muốn
Tập 3 bóng được tuyện muốn phần li
Thị chăm quá trình hảo vệ hợp
Thầy thầy
Tự cơ mà
Để nâng cà
Thầy là dúc cho rất nhiều những anh chị
Những hoa chất
Thậm chắc ra đồ duyện
Thì là học xịp rồi
Tất tệ, tập thình bố
Và có những em là quý chương của những em
Tụi lấy em
Câu cảnh bánh măn quanh lòng như thế
Hãy đến với lớp học, có thể kiểu
Đông thầy với em
Bà sẽ dúc thầy em
Họt tốt mù vật li
Hãy gọi em trong ngày thầy giang
Tối lấy
Túc tất cả em
Họt tốt